[Music]
Chile is one of the world's leading
producers of lithium the stuff that goes
into all of our smartphone laptop and
electric car batteries but to see how
lithium is pulled from the earth I went
to visit the operations of the mining
giants sq.m hello Ashley how you doing
finally here my guide through the mines
is Alejandro butch err
he's a cheerful engineer who has spent
years working in the great void when I
think of something like a lithium-ion
battery in a laptop or even a Tesla with
thousands of batteries it's what like a
spoonful of lithium batteries you would
say no in a night pad or in a cell phone
you can have something like a spoonful
in a car you could have maybe 10 to 15
kilos over of Lee tune it's the nearby
Andes Mountains that make these mines
possible over millions of years minerals
from the mountain is leached into the
ground then they collect together and
form huge soft beds rich in lithium
sulfate potassium and boron companies
like sqm PUC water up through the beds
and store the mineral rich liquid in
large ponds from there it's up to the
Sun to do its thing and evaporate away
the water leaving the minerals and salt
behind and nowhere evaporates better
than Chile
now we are heading for the first part of
the pond operation there's a lot of puns
those are pretty this is the first point
you can see the salts forming in the
surface you get salt parking spaces
[Laughter]
that's gonna be crazy because you
already have the harsh heat and cold and
then you have all this salt just pick up
track suffer a lot but the other
equipment we made them from a special
steel that really works good here
and now we're moving to the little ponds
that are only two of the 44 million
square meters that we have here this
point we made it so we can experience
what is the little brine
when we have it in the big pond sweet we
cannot sample so we made this little
pump what exactly is this this is my
nation boy magnesium chloride it's a
magnesium that we need to get rid of for
being able to produce the lesion in the
plants okay we will only send up the
track the liquid just the liquid just
the liquid okay so this is lithium what
are the odds that some part of this is
in my smartphone I couldn't guarantee it
but it's pretty sure that almost hundred
percent sure that part of your
smartphone went through this pond at
some point that's fast
at some point this is smart phone smart
phone juice you guys must be excited
that Tesla's are selling well and that
everybody is getting into your cars now
it's very interesting but it it puts a
lot fresher on us so we will more than
double our capacity probably in four
years
[Music]
Julie may have the largest lithium
deposits in the world but it started to
fall behind countries like Australia and
China when it comes to production and in
China it's a one-stop shop with the
mining and battery production happening
together this is a leap delaying
companies have been unwilling to take
maybe you could make the batteries here
in Chile well for me it would be
excellent but the company we're experts
in hydrology works but in mining words
but in producing lithium if we put us to
produce batteries we're probably not
going to do it well things have been
extra tense lately between the mines and
the Chilean government the feds have put
strict quotas on lithium production and
they've also been trying to act tough in
save face after some politico's were
accused of taking bribes from the mines
[Music]
environmentalists are huge fans of the
mines either they say that water is
being sucked from nearby lagoons that
feed these flocks of stunning flow
meters what we do here has absolutely no
impact to the community but we're still
responsible what's happening with them
we need to do counting of the flamingos
every year they identify them by the
feathers on the tail so they can
differentiate every from England
the miners here work for a week and then
take a week off because of the dry hot
salty conditions but there are some
on-the-job perks this sunsets here are
everyday amazing you have all these
different colors that only women know
the names every day and you don't get
tired of that it's really beautiful
[Music]
alejandra has a point not so much about
the colors that only women apparently
know but about the beauty of the mines
these odd marvels make the modern world
run let Tesla's flamingos breeding
program begin
[Music]
[Music]
you